hello ladies and ladies and gentlemen
it's me Jake and welcome welcome it's
episodes you know come on I'm not even
gonna say it I can't help myself it's
episode 139 this week I got a guest it's
my friend Marie polara valeriano oh can
you believe I just butchered his name
right out of the gate I wish there was
time to do this over but there's not
Marie valeriano is here this week kente
he's got a new CD coming out there it's
out it just came out coming out it was
coming out and now it's out his CD is
out of the closet and totally it can
have sex with whoever it wants its grown
up it's grown up but it's it's a it's a
new CD it's called rusty cow you can get
it everywhere we're going to talk about
it later on but first let me just
mention my sponsor it's me surprised him
go to Detroit this week to the comedy
castle in Detroit may 14 through 16 may
21 to 24 I'm back in Washington DC at
the DC improv please y'all come to that
I love the DC improv kind of looking
forward to it maybe they'll be a live
podcast I don't know jun 5 to 7 i'm in
new york city at gotham comedy club in
june 22 to 27 then with another show the
29th i'm going to be in London London
that's in England ladies and gentlemen
that's the one I'm going to I'm gonna be
the Soho Theatre in London England jun
22 through 27 with another show in the
29 I'm you know what you go to their
website go to my website to go to their
website though please throw me a bone
that makes my numbers look good and
that's really what that's really what
the world is about is making your
numbers look good who cares about
anything else besides you numbers I
do i do I care about your feelings
because I feel like your feelings are
important more important than your
numbers and I feel pretty good I'm glad
you're here and I hope you're glad
you're here crank it up if you're on the
treadmill and if you're on if you're in
the car driving around just relax maybe
you want to go into airplane mode so no
one could call you right now I say that
all the time but people call me quite
often during the podcast because I
forget my own advice about airplane mode
and if you don't have airplane mode
don't don't feel bad about yourself not
everyone not everyone has airplane mode
but just because that phone rings
doesn't mean you have to answer it just
remember that sometimes I want to say
that out loud to people but i don't i
was in chipotle the other day shout out
to chipotle i love that place from
behind this kid with a skateboard and he
puts his skateboard on one that you know
the high tables were in lying next to
these high tables and he just puts his
skateboard sets it wheels down on top of
the table somebody's gonna eat their
lunch where his wheel that rolled in the
street through god knows what and I'm
not trying to judge this young man I'm
just saying well I am judging him about
his putting a skateboard on the table
but wherever he goes that's his business
but there's dog urine in the streets
that's the least of what could be on
those skateboard wheels that's now on
the table where someone's going to eat
their lunch not me because I saw him do
it so I did another table where someone
else put something terrible on it before
I got there and so I didn't see it but
that's also how we build up our immune
systems isn't it really we expose
ourselves to what's on the wheels of the
skateboards of the young people all
across America thank you for listening
and please enjoy Marie valeriano here we
go
we gotta get going oh man yeah we don't
have time we don't have all day you
gotta go pick a kid up I never decided
which one yet yeah you don't you don't
always pick up your own kid sometimes
like to vary it up okay can you oh I'm
sorry how are we yeah yeah we're gonna
this is oh okay believe me all right low
threshold for what I'd consider a show
oh well then yeah I'm your perfect guest
glad you could make it I'm glad you
could make it oh so here we are as this
is it and this okay this is great I'm
it's good to be back it hasn't changed a
bit no well there's a few other it's
hard to tell when there's been a new
additions to this room because it's sort
of constantly in the state of things
getting dumped and then put away and
then thrown away and then more things
coming sure I'm glad you I'm glad you
have this I'm glad my I've you've been
to my podcast studio / office slashers
is very tidy are you get right are you a
minimalist kind of guy or no my wife is
extremely anal in Greek so that
combination is keep it clean or she gets
mad but that's even in your room yeah
yeah yeah my wife only comes to get me
in here to make me go to some other
thing she don't make me no she makes you
yeah she tries not to cheat rise not
that she tries not to go into my space
because she'll go she'll just it'll make
me angry so I'm not gonna go in there
your space makes her angry yeah if it's
messy if it's messy will she throw
things away or put them away or no no
she'll just complain to me about it
although when I when we first moved in
together it was like a I Love Lucy
episode or something there was a big bag
of stuff being thrown out and I went
through it I'm like this is my blanket
and this is my shirt why are you really
it was there was like a bad sitcom scene
I'm like why are you throwing this away
just cuz it was on the full you haven't
worn it and that's that blankets kind of
smelly Michael we can wash the blanket
she's like well why don't you well do it
now just let me keep it Wow
wait let me just ask you about your
blanket huh is this is this a blanket
that was on a bed or is it you have a
blanket that you just tap around the
house to cover up in case you get chilly
I carry with me it's right it's here
right here take a look his name is bongo
so he's been with me since fourth grade
it not read out out out okay okay now I
had a blanket it's funny I still have it
too I fought for it because I told her
it reminded me of freedom yeah I think a
blanket means freedom to a lot of people
means you could get your free to go
sleep on the couch yeah exactly whatever
you want so I kept my I kept my blanket
I won that battle I won that battle I'm
glad you were able to keep your blankets
and your shirt sounds like a nice shirt
and a bowl and I kept the ball too what
was the bowl it's just a blue bowl I've
had since college it's about I don't
know it's good it's good size for
popcorn oh so it's not a regular site
like every morning your breakfast no no
no its just oh it's a popcorn bowl it's
an occasional comes into service yeah
yeah well those are the kind of thing
it's important to have that around
that's freedom is freedom also also need
is a ball in a blanket so I can eat is a
bowl and blanket here you can hit the
road I feel a book coming on I know you
just released your CD but I think you
got the bowl in a blanket okay it's it's
hot now this minimalist thing oh yeah
it's hot yeah I've been reading all
about it what do you get Europe on a
bowl in a blank you're up on a ball in a
blanket yeah ooh my knee a spoon maybe a
spoon lanius maybe it's matter now I've
only been married 10 years maybe i'll
get my spoon in the next five yeah i do
think you are gonna need a spoon you
don't mention that in the title of the
book you start start to get long yeah oh
yeah you do need a sound you can't turn
into that and then when it goes into a
movie you can't fit it on the marquee
mmm for the mole a blanket a bowl and a
spoon they're just trickle off so it's
like the man version of Eat Pray lover
man we eat what does it eat eat eat pray
man left no easy prey something love oh
there's another one in there oh is it
eat pray love I thought it was just eat
pray love okay I could be I didn't read
it so but you're allowed to have another
Bowl blanket spoon yeah but we're
putting hands in there and that's gonna
that's it's going to add to the to the
distance of the
length okay so unless we just go bowl
spoon blanket or blanket blanket bowl
spoon yeah or well you could put you
could do like on Twitter you put that
little a treble clef looking and thing
in there you know what I mean man sign
the an sign yet yeah it is it called the
answer just another name ampersand I
believe is the a circle is the outside
right and I don't know if the + sign is
I don't either okay but I know what a
treble clef is so do I i would probably
put bass clefs in between just to really
confuse people if i could find that on
my phone if there was a bass clef on
there i would love to win that what is
that's the sea with the cullen right if
I remember from my music theory well
it's it's more like a giant ' that's how
I think of the bass club but yes I can
understand giant ' how it's sort of a
sea but then you turned it up and it's
backwards yeah you know cuz it's that
way all right it is that way but it's
but it's forward it would be like if
you're looking at a see in a mirror
right now yes okay it would be like if
you were looking at it only goes upside
down like a mushroom like like the pi
sine will a/c is like this but the bass
clef is more like that so it's augmented
yeah Oh another musically so this is
great if you're listening like this and
like that did you get that did you enjoy
that everyone you didn't see our hand
side so just all you need to do is
Google bass clef and then you could skip
the rest of this oh the sea I see it
yeah and then I thread to throw in the
pi sine and confuse everybody oh I do
they have pie on the phone they've got
all those smiley faces and it turd with
a base on it you'd think there'd be a
pie in there hey I get that from a lot
of people that turd with the face on it
and I don't like the turd with a face on
it I think they're doing it to be funny
I think they can't believe that it's one
of the that it's one of the emojis but
emoji is a japanese word right right and
they don't poop they love boo oh they do
they love the poop with a face on it I
think it's based on a like a TV show
yeah he'll so poopy yeah it's gonna be a
tough visit I think for us to Japan
because I don't want it I guess I do
want to see that I take it back I
you want to see the show the zoo with a
face on it I want to see what it does i
wanted it's not worth learning japanese
for but if I was in Japan I would watch
it even if I didn't know if I there were
no subtitles i would just be like i just
need to see with that in place i'm not a
poop guy at all as a matter of fact I'm
at Marie V on twitter if you want to
tweet at me tweet anything you want but
no poop emojis please no poop in my toes
all like boob emojis they're weird
they're kind of gross and then there's
like somebody sent me a barfi an emoji
oh really yeah and now do those coming
out on twitter if you tweet them on on
your phone their phones i guess not
Twitter's i guess right do they wake up
to link them but people can see them on
their phone but if they look on the
internet online on a computer can they
see the emoji I don't know how I don't
know I didn't realize I cements but I
think this is a record for the pod
usually I right we wound up on something
that we don't know what we're talking
about but this may be the fast this is
out of the gate man yes we hey we don't
know anything let's just turn the mics
on and it's and it's such a basic like
how could we ever possibly find that out
I don't know who could tweet and I could
go look at it on the combatants scream
four inches from your head we don't have
time for that or just ask the 13 year
old next door yeah i'm curious about
[ __ ] emojis you mean if you could see
them on the computer if you want him on
your phone yeah that's my question we
learned about that in class yesterday
yeah 13 year olds I would love to I feel
like I could totally afford to hire a 13
year old and he might be or she might be
able to do a better job of you know
spearheading my career from this point
forward then the current people who are
in charge you might me um excuse me I'm
losing my voice I guess yeah man I mean
they're they're taking over everything
through the federal yeah for for a while
is the Nerds and now it's the nerdy 13
year olds have you ever watched their
YouTube's 13 year olds well there's a
lot of YouTube channels where it's just
a young person talking about things that
they're interested in okay now i have a
reviewing things or or you know giving
you tips on things mm-hmm and i've done
i've watched them just in terms of like
look I don't know what I'm doing maybe I
should go see someone who knows what
they're deserters
person have you seen the billboards of
the people who've got 200,000 people
watching them on YouTube know where are
those you're driving down the street and
there's a pretty girl lying on her side
and it says 238,000 YouTube followers
into her name I haven't seen that yeah
is that in town or set on the road the
poop emoji world would start looking at
some billboards really now we gotta get
now we gotta get a billboard yeah yeah
maybe ah no I think someone else gets in
the billboard I think that's what
happens you get to be so popular making
little videos on your phone and putting
them on YouTube that then eventually
they give you a billboard they used to
give you a TV show now you get an import
now you just get a bill for a while
$500,000 billboard deal I don't know if
she even gets paid for the billboard oh
really that's the new also the new thing
in show business the new the new thing
is we're it's a hobby oh yeah we do it
for free yeah we may I'm not getting
paid for this for this ya know oh this
is not this doesn't pay I don't bow out
now we have pencil Robin jr. walk off 60
minutes or whatever he did the other day
who did Robert Downey jr. walked off it
was a 60 minutes it was maybe CNN
because I guess about because they kept
asking about his drug addiction and he
was there to promote the Avengers and I
probably would've walked off too if
because the guy just kept going you know
cuz do you know cuz you used to do a lot
of drugs and you think that affects your
life right now like well aren't we here
to promote Avengers yeah but I mean he
stopped doing the drugs then he stopped
doing the drugs a while ago and it's
worked out for him mmhmm yeah yeah I
feel like I've got my drug used to this
sort of a manageable level I could tell
ya right now I know you don't do crystal
meth or this place would be spotless
yeah we tidied up a little bit i think
that met though that state that's bad
for you start picking little sores and
your skin and right it's not a there's
not a picture of there's not an example
of the guy who's doing meth and its
really working for him right now there's
not your don't think you're gonna get
like sticky fingers off a meth like they
got off you know heroin this video this
yes stones doing heroin got some really
great music I don't think anybody out
there is really busting out the next you
know the wall by pink floyd by doing
yes style maybe I don't know maybe stay
off the meth that's a good public
service mmm if we learn anything today
off the meth today I notice you were in
a hat today yeah where I have because
it's from Scotland and I know you're
Scottish no I'm not Scottish you know
know know what you just put away with
all this haggis right yeah it's sweet of
you to bring haggis I mean you're the
first part you're the first guest who's
ever brought haggis i was thinkin what
does this place need the place that has
everything that's happening is I try not
to leave any food in here because
because you could easily get lost
underneath some things I mean I take it
back there are some peanuts over there
in a can okay one I want some nuts no
you're wearing a hat I am I wearing a
hat I can see her hair is peeking out
from under your hat uh-huh and you've
got some great I've got some great I do
have some gray yes I was just listening
to the radio this morning and they were
saying in Britain it was the BBC part of
you know that anyway the BBC part of the
radio with the BBC part of the NPR part
of it okay sure anyway and they were
talking about people in Britain are now
getting their hair dyed gray what it's a
fashion it's a fashion a thing you know
what that means you'll be doing that in
like seven years because England rd beat
always beats a song here in the United
States yeah yeah I nor hair gray well no
we're ahead of the trend but you and I
we just need to embrace it all we need
to do is have them hit the spots that
haven't turned gray yet are they going
full gray like I think they're going mad
rang gray are you really yeah I think so
we should we need to get we need to do a
tour in England you and I right now with
the gray hair I got to get one of those
hats so we'll go on with the hats first
it's Scottish yeah i know but that's its
scotland is like the Hat of England
look you see what I'm saying I do you
have very much um so um we go on stage
with a hats and then we'd off our caps
yes reveal our bright grey looking and
then we're gonna have to do something I
mean that's then then then I guess I got
a scar Jake you get you get you got to
land the plane is just a comedy show
from their own house but the beginning
part you got to see the beginning it's
very exciting yeah let's see the 13 year
olds go gray not going to happen when
they start dying their hair grade that's
when it that's when that's when you
really get mad right I mean finally
that's the last straw yeah it was like
no one respects us no one wants to
listen to us anymore because we got gray
hair and lug the 13 year olds dye their
hair gray I've got it's over I revolt
against them at that point I think I
think that's what I do that's it i'm
dying their hair gray at school i have
to look that up that's interesting
anyway i'm wearing a hat because i am
way behind on a haircut oh really yeah
i'm just letting my hair I've I don't
really we don't really need to talk
about Marie's haircut in history but my
hairdresser who has been cutting my hair
for like 15 to 20 years man or a woman
woman Shauna uh she got sick don't you
could cut hair anymore she's an elderly
woman anyone's here not anymore she's
out of the haircut yeah but she was but
she's back but i lost her number and she
was gone for so long uh-huh i finally
found her number so i'm getting my
haircut on saturday but I'm like
probably two months past it was cutting
your hair in the meantime did you my
wife I went to my wife's hair dresser
and I pay my hairdresser 20 bucks to cut
my hair sure so have you ever gone to a
woman's hair dresser I've had some
expensive haircuts in the pack yes I'm
like how much should i tip Carla your
hairdressers liked it for twenty bucks
tipper 20 doll I'm like how much is the
haircut and it was a lot and she did a
good job but still i'm not paying our
you're not gonna tell me what the air
cut costs that's all moves hunter bucks
a hundred dollars hmm fucking's ladies
are stupid right well no that's the god
geyser I'm stupid for going but God the
women's aren't more expensive I get it
colored
you didn't know this is natural gray do
you mean it's a hundred including color
even if you don't know unless if you get
color did you tack on another I don't
know what color 45 bucks footless sucks
I decided long ago mm-hmm not never to
walk in anyone's shadow that's what you
know I am I decided a long time ago that
that flow be sounded pretty good oh yeah
and so I bought a flowbee I've actually
worn out we're not almost worn out and
then I bought a new flow be let's put it
this way I've been cutting my own hair
for decades since the flowbee came out
yeah wow this is a little bit of an
autumn own card thing because it's
really short on the sides and low and do
you do that yourself as a viewing that
over bagels may I did this myself but I
can I'm able to do much more
conventional haircuts with the thing I
highly encourage you to invest the I
think it costs between fifty and seventy
dollars retro flowbee give it a try all
right you see what you think it's three
haircuts for my uh from my older free
haircuts from the twenty-dollar late
yeah it's less than one here one haircut
ships in the haircut you know haircut
rip off you've had some avant-garde
hairstyles in your day haven't you
mm-hmm well all yourself for ya
recommendations I had when it was really
long I had a guy had this Japanese guy
cutting my hair he was a gay japanese
guy on Sunset Boulevard that another
friend had wrecked a lady friend
recommended me to our sure and he was in
that and this was this is you know 20
years ago but he was in that eighty to a
hundred range for the haircut he was
very nice and the salon was very nice
and they you know they shampoo her I
don't need them to shampoo my hair I
think that's another lady thing like
yeah you're not doing me a favor by
shampoo in my hair I can do that I don't
need you to shampoo my hair but they'd
shampoo your hair and then they cut it
and give you a little massage and then
they'd style you know they they give you
that finale hairdo thing which is always
like either it's so good that you can
never repeat it yourself or it's so not
you that you feel like you've had a head
transplant I walked out of guys but my
problem with him was it was expensive it
took a long time to get over there still
am it would to Sunset Boulevard oh okay
and it would sometimes be not the
haircut that I wanted sure yeah you know
he would just even if you're getting the
same haircut every time they can't
they're cutting a lot of Peters remember
they'll remember you get a little bit of
what you want and a little bit of the
last haircut they did yeah yeah and one
thing I've noticed is hairdressers hate
notes like because I went by what time I
want my wife's twice or maybe three
times and I didn't really like it the
first time but then I said hey because I
had to go back like hey I really liked
what you did here last time but maybe
this time could you just not do this and
that and everything and she's like okay
whatever all right they don't lay I'm
like hey you're cutting my hair I just
thought maybe this is what I like but
the problem is you're paying a price
like she's an artist yeah I know man I
see a lot of time I understand I'm
designing a hairdo for you but mine's
like listen I'm trying to keep my wife
will cut my son's hair but she won't cut
my hair I'm like let's buy the Clippers
put it on for across the head every once
every two months I don't see why that's
a problem my hair you like you the
difference between a good haircut in a
bad haircut two weeks it'll just grow
out it'll be fine this is the thing with
the flow be not that I'm selling these
things I do there's what I'd be happy to
give you a haircut when we're done with
this the the beauty it's not about being
a cheapskate although that's where we
started off with this conversation right
it's about being in control I you may in
a on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10 is the
best haircut you may not get a 10 but
you don't get a 10 that often when you
go to someone else cutting your hair but
the flowbee is a pretty consistent eight
really you know it's go often often a
nine and it's always you are in charge
of it yeah you're deciding if you want
to take off a little more sure yeah
because I've been that one where it's
like hey could you take off a little bit
more in the front and then they take off
way too much yeah and then you do you
look weird they're busy they're cutting
a lot of people's hair a lot of heads
coming through that place you're only
cutting your own hair
yeah I might look into it I don't can
you still get a flowbee are they still
on the market oh yes you can't I just
like just bought this mean you can I
think it I think you can get it on
Amazon now is it a vacuum is I want to
remember we have to have your own vacuum
to hook it up to Oh Josie they don't
really tell you that in the small print
I would have bought a flowbee and I
would've been screwed you don't have a
vacuum cleaner I don't know if we have a
vacuum uter you hook it up to the hose
so it's better to have one that's got a
hope but hooks up to the hose in the
vacuum cleaner and that sucks your hair
up and then the Clipper clips it off oh
and you can alright and then you said
how long how long you want it to be this
is a good but this applies to anyone
listening I highly encourage you to get
the flowbee and please i'll have i'll be
happy to consult with you as i travel
over the country I mean I love to start
doing haircuts after the show but I
think I think you have to have a license
to cut people's hair is this is to go
back without going completely back to
the conversation we were having earlier
but my friend greg behrendt and I trying
to figure out this show where we would
do we would do the comedy show and then
we would cut people hear people's hair
how does he cut his own hair end of it
he I think he does cut his own hair well
sculpted that hair or he though the
Mohawk thing that he does yeah alright
well we'll be right back with the pros
and cons of the pocket fisherman after
this yeah I don't my dad just sold all
of his fishing gear he's at that point
in life where he is he's decided he's
never gonna go fishing again really yeah
huh and so he sold all of his fishing
gear he was excited about it yeah which
to me to me it had sort of a sadness to
it but yeah I'm trying to decide where
I'm at with my golf clubs oh yeah I got
you know what I meant where am I go I
just want Matt with my golf clubs I'm
not buying a new set yeah that's for
sure not maybe not thrown away but I'm
not buying a new set I wouldn't throw
them away I or sell them or I don't know
if he could sell my think my ex like I
bought mine in 99 or something like that
I think in theory you can sell
everything but how bad do you want
eleven dollars yeah you throw him out on
the front front yard and stick a price
on it I do want $11 actually if I could
if I mean it would if it was instant but
the amount of work you gotta do for
eleven dollars yeah don't give me eleven
dollars either a palimony
listening well i think i mentioned i was
on jury duty and that's coincidentally
about what they paid me for two days oh
you got paid you don't get it for the
first day uh-huh but i had to come back
the second day and so it was eleven
dollars and 22 cents sweetest eleven
dollars and 22 since you'll ever make
it's that weird thing it's like the it's
like residuals where they're
contractually obligated to pay you and
then you get a check for 22 sensors
right sure oh my god costs more to mail
it than it does to send you the check
mm-hmm I have that sure yeah eleven
dollars 22 cents what were you just
saying Joe jury duty you know what I
learned about jury duty what if you can
push it or put it off until the week of
the fourth of July the week of christmas
or the week of thanksgiving yes I knew
that I'd which might not the last one to
the week of the fourth of July I was
there for one day and we were let go
halfway through the day yeah I've done
that in the past this year we're going
to be out of town on the fourth of July
and I didn't want to I would it happened
to me that they came when the notice
came it was this week and I was in town
this week and it was so I said I'll do
it you're gonna be out of town on the
fourth of July yeah we're gonna be
flying back from Great Britain I thought
we want to go on over there to do a
little legwork for they have to whatever
awesome excellent I thought we had a
thing I thought we met every year at the
parade the fourth of July period I
thought that was exactly we may be home
for the actual fourth we may be
traveling on the third okay but what I'm
saying is I couldn't do jury duty that
week because of how sure okay interns
it's okay that makes sense yeah very
little uh cases are heard on the fourth
of July yeah Christmas or the weekend of
you know right before the Christmas home
yeah week yeah and Thanksgiving this was
gonna be a very easy case that I
actually got cold I admitted to it
already know if that happens you're out
oh but it was a nice th easier than that
hmm you couldn't get much easier than
that no well you don't have to go in if
he okay they don't have a jury come down
and go check out this guy you did I did
it will deliberate
we'll be back in four hours hey I was
just talking about it on the podcast
that came out to one before this one but
yeah uh this is my chance to actually be
on a jury was supposed to be a short
trial I was called in on monday i could
have done the whole thing but they
ejected me off of the panel re looking
forward to it you sound like well the
thing was he we went on on monday we got
called down to the Roman he talked about
it and then we had to come back Tuesday
because the lawyers weren't finished
asking everybody questions before they
started throwing people out and he said
all in the judge he the judge said we
would be done by Thursday so I thought
well this would be I can feel good about
myself that I did my civic TV and I'm
not it's not interfering with my way
it's a pain in the ass to have to go
down to yeah and I got into it with a
parking guy you have to scan your badge
to get in and these candy badge to get
out but it's not at the court parking
lot it's at they it's like a block away
it's three blocks away three blacks are
well from the court there's a bunch of
court building all got here it's but you
park at the Disney Center this beautiful
Disney Hall yeah yeah I remember Gary
building yeah and the parking attendant
the badge didn't scan when I went to get
out he said well if you scanned that to
get in it should let you back out and
they had given me a different bit when
you everybody hands in their badge and
then it doesn't have your name on it has
a number on it and they just hand you
back the badge along with your check
which has your name on it and then I go
to get out and the person whose badge I
got evidently had not scanned themselves
in and then I got into an argument with
this guy about whether or not i used the
badge to get in and i said look there
was a mixup and he goes are you lying to
me you know it's like come on i'm lying
to a parking attendant to get free
parking at the disney center during the
day on a tuesday white what did you
think I came down here what kind of scam
do you suppose that I'm right I show him
the check for eleven dollars and 22
cents i go here now do you believe me it
goes no I don't know yeah I said you're
gonna apologize to me I just SAT there
there's people lined up behind me and he
goes I'm not gonna apologize to you and
then it was like I realized right he
probably gives less of a [ __ ] about the
people behind me than I do right yeah of
course so I was just had to leave oh it
was a bad poker game it felt bad yeah he
defeated me in the who's the biggest
jerk
well that's that's good though and you
don't don't don't get into who's the
biggest jerk with a parking attendant
they're gonna win every time no and I
that I've been in that situation but
have you ever gotten an argument with
one of those guess oh yeah I gotta do it
I but I get the last laugh um I got into
it the grove mm-hmm cuz uh my card
wouldn't read and it was good and she
died remember she just gave me such a
bad attitude and then she finally had to
punch it in and then I asked her for a
receipt and that made her even more mad
because she had her hand write it so she
hand wrote the receipt and like through
almost practically threw it in my car
and then slammed the book of receipt
blank receipts down on her little ledge
and stormed away so I grab the little
receipts uh thing off the thing all of
them all of them in case I ever need a
receipt yeah well I'd in case I ever
need a legitimate receipt I didn't get
to serve on the jury that I was summoned
for but in the jury of this crime that
you just described I find you guilty of
being awesome and also of a winning and
Twitter handle again at Marie V at Marie
V if you need a parking receipts we
treat me for a parking see ya you bring
them to your shows and hand them out of
here party favors now don't you get you
don't get a pass like you don't get a
aren't you trick Johansson kind of pass
know if they go around to everybody so
they got 36 people in there and they
give you the sheet of you got
everybody's got to say their name not
your name you don't say your name uh-huh
you're wearing just a number so you say
what's your job and if you're married
and what you do for a living and sure
you know if you know anybody who's a
attorney or a cop if you've ever been
arrested and whatnot and so I have to
say yeah I'm a comedian of stand-up
comedian and so I say that and then
people I suppose look at you to see if
they recognize you it's not to the
demographic is slightly different than
the comedy club audience okay sure at
the place we're surprising to me how
many people on that in the jury thing
Hadley
of jobs no not coming it was a video
director and a editor and something else
but then there's a lot of there was
there was a fair share of I'm a food
server in an actor okay view those oh
yeah but there was also tow truck truck
driver who did not want to discuss the
encounters that he had with the police
in the past oh really yeah gimme and he
would you know they're asking about it
was domestic violence so they're asking
about violence and if people have been
in fights and he was like yeah i've been
in some fights and they're asking him
about self-defense he goes yeah I know
what that's like to defend yourself I
know what that's like oh man I wonder is
it seemed like that would be he had some
good stories but I did not want to be on
the jury sure he was like I can't I
don't know if I can be fair you know
every case that I've heard of domestic
you know somebody's complaining about
domestic violence they did it yeah I
know nobody's faking that that's what
that was his thing and there were a lot
of people trying to get kicked off the
jury my in my opinion you get kicked off
the jury just by having an opinion oh
yeah shy bet yeah I've never been chosen
so I don't know yeah well you'll see
okay I laughed at the defense attorney
when she act she says has anyone here
ever witnessed um domestic violence
either in person or on TV or movies like
what kind of question is that that's
well I guess she's thorough yeah I bet
that I don't sound something like that
truck tow truck driver was not like a
triple a tow truck driver he was not out
there helping he was the guy who was
like toad you if you park too long or
maybe that's why I had all this fight
school well I think that you're both I
think that tow truck drivers are both
those things oh really yeah you're a
triple a driver when you're helping
people and then also sometimes the
police call you to tow away or you got
your company has a contract to toe
people out of this lot so you're out how
you're out doing whatever you do and
then you get a call from the dispatcher
that goes hey get this you should put on
the boy you take off the white hat and
put on the black hat yeah all right yeah
I didn't know that's not me where I
think it might be like that Sherlock
Holmes hat where he just oh oh front to
back Wow
would be great if I'd like a little
something so you have to do it yourself
you'll see just do it anyway and I love
pants like that that's more of a skirt
right yeah it is yeah and only if it
made that noise hoodie Oh Jake just
changed his pants speaking of pants
mm-hmm what are you wearing on stage
nowadays I'm just curious cuz i think
i'm going back to the suit are you i
think i'm going back to the suit you
know I tried the suit i would say three
or four months ago in the new irvine
improv mm-hmm you know it's a 500-seat
theater it's beautiful I'm like I'm
gonna try a suit sure Ike was not i
don't know if i was more uncomfortable
in that suit or if I was more
uncomfortable the first time onstage I
don't know which it was so not I don't
know I didn't like it I didn't like have
you ever been a suit guy I'm not much of
a suit guy I look good in a suit now
wear suits but I only wear suits it's
like this I have this outfit and then I
have a really expensive suit I have
nothing in between so you're wearing now
I'd say let me just describe your outfit
you've got some lace up vans on black
with a little red tongue and they're red
on the bottom two you're wearing some
jeans not super fashion eat jeans like
my ratty up hanging out guy jeans you're
wearing a jacket that looks like a very
sporty kind of guy who works on cars but
this is your dress up jacket I will wear
this tie wear this on stage I'll wear
this tonight probably it's a nice it's
it's a very stylish kind of zip up
jacket yeah it's like a winner almost
like a windbreaker type thing made by
Quicksilver and then of course you've
got your Scotsman my Scottish at plaid
plaid lads what it's not a newsboy cap
but it's got a bet I don't know what
they call those but it would be kind of
news will you wear the hat onstage I
have but I don't like to but it's a it's
weird and not to dissect stand-up comedy
or live performances because I don't
know if I can bore your audience more Oh
believe me it's really the people who
want to know are still listening okay
everybody and I think every piece of
clothes clothing you wear onstage says
something about you oh sure you're
sending little sublet we're all sending
subliminal messages all the time to the
people who are looking at us yeah so I
like the Hat I doesn't doesn't do it for
me I think it's sending the wrong
message as i do feel the suit is sending
the wrong message oh yeah i just like to
died the message that i'm trying to send
with my on stage outfit is this is a
this this is a big deal for me and I'm
excited to be here it's a special thing
and I want you to be quiet they were a
loud suit I the thing about the cap
though with the brim is a lot of times
than light you get a shade over the top
part of your face yeah you don't want to
do that I need people to be able to see
the top part of my thighs it's the best
part a very well the bottom part is the
business part of my shirts where I'm
really doing the work but the top part
also let's not to be underestimated
mm-hmm no I agree but but um I do i do
live by the rule of dressing better than
the audience yeah um but i but i will
general i will not hard to do nowadays
so we yeah i know and obviously and not
hard to dress nicer than the comedian
before you either oh geez sometimes some
of these guys some of these kids these
youngsters kids it's like i did you
smell the lawn I know you didn't know
the lawn cuz I know you're you're lazy
there's no way in the department here's
honey why don't you get rid of your lawn
mowing clothes so i did i do hold that
but i still like i buy i have i have a
stage clock on stage clothes and then i
usually only wear for work you only wear
them today this jet this jet this jacket
goes back and forth mm-hmm um this
jacket I can do I have another jacket
that I wear not morally upright she kind
of a thing yeah do you know who knew d
is nudie the suit designer no no he's
one who designed all those spangly
country and western Oh suits with like
the big you know emblazoned embroidered
eagle on the back of a white
yeah I were those how great I can't
believe he felt like the other suit was
too much to do it how do you spell nudie
I don't know shall I google it real
quick no that's okay I like the fact
that his name is nudie but he makes
clothed clothing yeah yeah I was yeah
I'm on board with you yeah it's
interesting that now just to go back to
the top part in the bottom part of your
face yeah okay because I think I
remember that you had said to me you had
a I know I got part of my face oh yes I
you have a you have a new comedy CD
which you've made with the bottom part
of your face I did I made it with a
bottom part of my face I do and did you
consider making it DVD so that you'd be
able to see all the parts of your face I
don't have that good of a face huh
interesting ya know how it's ed yeah I
feel like CD is is a good way to go
because the cost of producing it is
obviously much lower and you can you can
make it and have it out and you know
you've archived that material and you
could move on to to start creating your
next chunk sure and as a guy who kind of
went used I'm trying to not sound like
an a-hole here but I kind of podcasting
took me to another level in my stand up
to in what sense it like I became more
known through podcasting yes through my
podcast mm-hmm so people the people who
know me listen to podcasts CDs so sirius
XM so they're listening so I just said
re i'll go CD because most of the people
who i will reach that i'll definitely
reach our listeners this may be what's
holding my podcast back aside from the
fact that it's deadly boring um is is
that people are used to seeing my face
well yeah and now it could be no this is
just like what about his face so you
need a television show I do maybe that's
we were talking before this about
periscope maybe maybe that's right why
don't you set up a camera in here I know
I'd love this would be its vide its
photogenic this yeah this is great yeah
I guess I got to figure out what cam
what camera do you get do
to get a what do you get a GoPro just
shoot it on your phone I max hi max hi
max get a big camera so the camera is
actually as big as this way yeah it's
about that big I'm not to blow out one
wall to get the camera in here and I
think it's three guys at least and that
thing your fans will appreciate the
effort yeah they won't now so I went CD
on that route just kind of um that was
my logic now that periscope is probably
gonna be the next big thing I'm gonna
yeah I'm always one behind I'm hoping
the periscope beats meerkat that's the
other instant video what a meerkat I
don't know a guy named periscope but
it's owned by someone else and it was
integrated into Twitter it's a video
it's another video instant watch me
making videos right now ok we're all
tuning into each other's just dribbles
nonsense I mean I like to think of this
as just a real cut above driveling
nonsense the spot oh yeah cut above but
what's the name of your CD it's called
rusty cow rusty cow hold on and what's
the what's wow are you brought it along
did you ask me to bring it along yeah oh
this is great i'm gonna look at it well
you tell me what do you want me to tell
you well I want you to tell me I see I
wanted you to explain rusty cow but I
see now on the front of you i'm just
gonna describe this because people are
used to use it listening to you talk
sure i'm gonna let them listen to me
talk and then this maybe i'm laying the
groundwork now for mark from ice next
DVD which is only going to be a CD ok
great less initials you will write and
you actually do get a photo so people
can look at this while they're listening
i like to think they do that especially
its specially driving right it's better
than the download where you can't look
at a thing right but the on the front is
you not really slapping yourself on the
forehead sort of slapping yourself in
the eye with the palm of your hand and
in front of you on the table with one
with the other hand you're holding on to
a half-empty bottle of whiskey and that
looks like a pint of whiskey and then
next to that is a half-empty bottle
babies bottle
with the nipple on it of milk mm-hmm so
rusty cow to me is the rust is the
whiskey and the cow is the milk is then
right it's a drink it's called the rusty
cal that put scotch and milk and you
give it to you baby when you want to go
to sleep and what what parenting book do
you get that rusty cat uh you know you
get it on a CD called uh Marie valerian
order to make out rusty I didn't make up
rusty kalia you did uh-huh because I
there's ingredients to it on the inside
but I ver you mean this is full of
scotch and milk well their ingredients
on how to make it now ready as a recipe
but not the ingredient no I tried that
and just ruined all the cds yeah it's
cuz it's card what comes in a cardboard
sleeve I went with a cardboard sleeve
online to its ekalaka logically sound oh
this is nice I see the track names potty
training mm-hmm this is gonna be good
raising us white people track number
eight man I'm like I'm like is this man
keep up keep this copy of course your CD
yes um dying and treadmills I can't wait
oh really huh so pre-show and post-show
are two tracks pre-show and poachy oh I
did I you know you're a fan of music yes
are you fan of Stevie Wonder [ __ ] yes
okay living in the city yes do you know
that part where kind of breaks down and
they go into like New York just like I
pictured it you know or living for the
city I forget where they kind of talk it
concerns of sensing a little bit of just
the living just enough for the city oh
no I can't think of it now I know it's
hard to get the melody that's but that's
that's all you know I'm talking about
and then it breaks down and it has that
since it a they saw this attack yeah and
it has that scene where these guys get
off the bus and they get arrested yes a
scene it's like it breaks down into a an
audio see tonal telling a little story
okay so it doesn't almost this mono
thing and so I use that I'm like oh you
know be cool since I'm gonna be miked
anyway why don't I when I just leave the
mic on before the show and leave the mic
on after the show so I'm just just just
us talking before the show and then us
talking it for the show
so you're in the audience that's their
can hear you doing the pre-show and the
now now now it's just guys talking I'm
talking to the other comment like the
comics who open for me and people who
come out to the show and stuff did you
have them what how did you I had a live
on oh is that how you recorded the show
with the love oh yeah lob and then a
directional uh-huh and then I don't know
the sound guy had had the whole place on
my guess this is too technical I know I
don't think I'm not a very good somebody
hire somebody to handle all that oh you
you had helpers oh yeah oh yeah yeah I
can't want it huh I can't do any of that
sure you can I came in periscope dude
periscoping by the way is what we used
to call taking your penis out of your
zipper well periscope the one that
hooked up to twitter is not that no i
mean you could do that I why not but I
think that you would get thrown off
Twitter I think you can can you get
thrown off twittering I don't know cuz I
there's a for some reason do you have
porn stars that follow you that follow
me on Twitter oh god I hope so I do and
then I will follow them back and then
follow everybody who follows you back
now but I followed a few point and then
every once awhile you'll be scrolling on
your feet and there will be a giant porn
scene on your phone then you're kind of
kind of embarrassing so oh the porn
stars are posting porn actual porn
actually add round chick around where oh
yeah right on their lives over the city
yes so I you know so if they do that
then I'd stop following because I could
be sitting there with my wife and all of
a sudden there's this porn scene that
comes on right it's more of a single
man's yeah yeah it from their point of
view they're helping you out yeah and so
I'm a porn star you're following me this
is what you want here you go yeah I
guess for their fans yeah but it's funny
a lot of porn stars are fans of comedy
interesting you wouldn't think they had
a sense of humor well I did go to UM
Eddie ifs buts o Lord vodcast bus party
rookie yeah and speak if anybody has
gonna get thrown off Twitter it's gonna
be that he had some he had some porn
stars at the podcast bust party thing
yeah and that was fun he had I didn't
realize I feel like he has always been
so nice to me when I've met him and
interacted with him and so that you know
I've obviously I've listened to his
podcast and I've been on his podcast but
he he
kind of did a version of it that I was
on there was slightly different than the
version that's that he usually is
because it's he couldn't be could be a
little he's a racy sure yes races good
word I mean if you want to know we were
talking earlier you wanted to know where
to buy a dildo and high head now we have
to go down that road no we don't have to
that was just that was a joke position
of a conversation we had about where
would you buy a dildo and it was in the
context of all explain it Oh case in the
context of buying joke gifts for people
at bachelorette parties or whatever
hours and stuff well I have a guy friend
who's comedian whose favorite um
favorite gift for a wedding gift is a
big black dildo with a crank on it what
yeah just just the biggest so many times
does he get married he gives it to other
people oh no that's not the one that he
received hello Mike favor well it was a
good misunderstanding that on purpose
hmm you're good no people should buy
this CD man rusty cow rusty cow the
itune itunes amazon all that stuff Marie
valeriano calm Marie valeriano calm
people should get the actual I I'm a big
fan of getting the actual CD me too and
is it because we're music lovers do you
think i'm not i'm not sure i'd just you
can put this into your computer and ipod
thing but you can also look at it and I
do get that if you buy the download you
can see but you can't name picture don't
get the liner notes you don't get you
know all that's inside there's liner
notes there's a little you know thank
yous and stuff like that credits and
everything like that and a how to make a
ressie cow but not the ingredients we
went through that yeah and now I'm hot
this is hot off of a hot off the press
it came out May first was that 33 days
ago four days ago yeah 3 or 4 days ago
say uno is what we called it yeah mayo
de uno uno de mayo uno de mayo uno de
mayo and you sit around playing a card
game all day right mm-hmm yeah right
which card game
I'm not a big card though oh yeah I
didn't know that your dragon okay i know
i've never played i don't think i've
ever played oh no you never play you
have a little girl you never played uno
no you're a bad father I i'm not a big
game at a gamer i'm not a game that i've
tried to get into it you know I'm and I
am I'm continue to try but this i bought
this game the Jackie Kashian all
recommended called settlers of catan oh
come on have you bought they have you
tried that game no you're like going
you're like going from maybe I'll try
checkers to like full-on gaming this is
not yet goes from zero to six again I
know she's a huge game nerd right you're
going from 0 to 60 though you're not
going 35 40 45 yeah no I'm getting an
xbox I'm doing call of duty it's going
right into it what's the learning curve
on call of duty do you think if you just
bought an xbox and you tried to go on
the where you go online and play against
people it's just like you just get
assassinated and I think I played three
times before I stopped and then I sold
it really called area but you tried it
uh-huh I cuz i bought an xbox because i
thought it'd be cool to play with my
friend who I grew up with in jersey and
then some military guys I became friends
with on the road who come came out the
shows and stuff I started playing with
them and it was just it was pointless so
I stopped playing and then i sold it
somebody cuz they're too good yeah it's
literally like okay what do I when
you're dead yeah find you you're dead
I'm behind you you're dead behind you
you're dead yeah so it was not fun
there's no you like I said learning
curve is what you can do and what I did
is by a call of duty just for your
computer and play it that way you know
any play against a computer and is that
fun that's alright it's alright and what
how many times do you like gun games huh
you like gun games I do when I you know
when you get a gig when you're I do love
that you've got porn star and military
guys as your fans i know i'm not sure of
the kind of show that you're doing good
but i but i do love your fan base okay
um i guess when I'm on the road and
they've got a they've got a like a
coupon for an arcade uh-huh my favorite
thing to do is this Ombey how shoot a
zombie thing
are you a zombie guy well that's a bit
fun video game it's okay cuz they're not
then you're not shooting I'm not sure
about shooting people other people if I
would like that I used to date this girl
who every Friday we would go to the
movies and we go early to play the
zombie game and shoot zombies for like
20 minutes before the movie started yeah
the movies would you do that again at
the end of the movie or just know
sometimes yeah sure think that happen to
that girl I don't know I got shot by a
zombie was that back in the not here in
his room the zombie girlfriend really i
was here in Los Angeles yeah yeah yeah
that was here a lot of my back I don't I
moved here when I was young I mudra I
was like 20 21 or something like that so
a lot of my back in the day is still
still here into town back in the day but
in the town back in this town in the
city with the spec in the city mm-hmm
living just enough for the city it's
living just enough for the city uh-huh
so then you know what I'm talking about
yes I'm not confusing that with another
song right no I don't think so except i
don't remember the song as well as i
mean i remember that part of the song
but i don't remember the other part in
the song where the but i'm gonna let
hope that's the right I've got a lot of
googling to do oh yeah when this is
finished i hope that's the right song I
me because I'm talking about it in radio
and I could be doing the wrong Stevie
Wonder referencing the wrong Cindy
wonder stevie wonder song I windy wonder
is who I just met us both lucky if we
gotta you know pile of emails correct so
um do you ever consider I guess we've
talked to for a decent amount of time I
did have a thing that I wanted well it
just reminded me mm-hmm have a thing
that I've been thinking about lately
about do you ever see yourself moving
away from here or is this do you think
is your home now you moved did you I'm
assuming you came here for show business
I came here to get the heck out of New
Jersey that was it that was sole purpose
it II was too close to my home mm-hmm I
mean I had aspirations to be a musician
a guitar player and stuff like that but
I didn't get into comedy until probably
five years after I got out here mm-hmm
so I love it here I love it devotion
right there the you know it's everybody
always says you can surf and snowboard
in the same day nobody's ever done it
but people say that I think some people
have done it i Doan ever read anybody
you know you can surf and snowboard in
the same day have you done it no but you
can do it I think it's just for people i
think that's just for people to be able
to say technically you could do it but
it wouldn't be a great experiment be fun
I don't make it up super early to do one
of them and then leave in the middle of
having a good time right in order to get
there just in time to do a little bit of
the other one before it was dark and
then you have to drive home and traffic
yeah that's not fun so that's not no
that's not that kind of what you could
but you could it's nice to know that you
could surf one day and then get a good
night's sleep and then snowboard the
next day in the winter yes there's no
warning can only ever in the winter they
leave the part out where you can't
snowboard 365 days it's that's that you
cannot beat you yes you can do that but
you can only do that as else you can
only snowboard in the winter thing goes
without saying a little bit I just want
to be clear if I'm gonna put it on a
license plate oh yeah I think there are
probably some parts of very northern
Canada and the Arctic and Antarctic
where you can snowboard year round true
but we don't live there no and I don't
think you could probably surf there you
wouldn't want to I think the water gets
really heavy yeah yeah it would get that
blushy that's sort of yeah yeah that's
not a good put some cherry syrup in
there you know make it a slushie mmm no
I love it here i don't think i would i
sometimes I think if something horrible
were to happen and I ended up alone I'd
moved to Costa Rica but that's about it
really for the surf or just the surf in
the remote kind of the remoteness kind
of thing Lou out how to dodge slop
margarita ill kind of feeling yeah yeah
I figure if something horrible happened
and I'm alone then I have nothing here
so we wouldn't be alone cuz I'm here you
mean all of us are you'll be the wall
might be part of the horrible so not
only your family all of your friends are
taking yeah it's not like yeah and I'm a
horrible underlined you know like if
something horrible happen and I was
alone so this could include like let's
say you go to lunch and you eat
something that gives you amnesia yeah
you might forget that you were supposed
to go to Costa Rica rotation
yeah good you don't know you've been to
Costa Rica no yes of course affected
I've been there like three times i love
it my wife is from New Zealand sure as
you I think no I do know that but people
are always saying to her that's where I
want to move I want to move to New
Zealand oh when the [ __ ] goes down in
America you know when when the when the
political thing that I don't like
happens in America are willing to know
Xena and then she asked him if they've
ever been in this no I've never been
they don't know I what do they know
they'll Americans don't know anything
about New Zealand except the hobbit
movies that's all they know and those
are fictional yeah but they don't know
if they didn't really take place in New
Zealand they took place in another place
that's it that's New Zealand is doubling
for middle-earth it isn't really men see
that I don't think I factoring that in
hmm i don't feel like people are
factoring that didn't know they're not i
know i have been know a little more than
the average American about New Zealand
for instance the band the Thompson Twins
now lived there do they mm-hmm are they
from there nope but that's just were
they retired to the fin brothers are
from there yes yeah Crowded House not
twins not twins not twins brothers
though yeah but not twins okay twins
kind of freaked me out do you know twins
um I know one twin of a lot of twins but
trying to think of yes there was a
comedy team in San Francisco when I
started Fran and gents Alameda and they
were they were Twite Franz at franza a
twin I think Fran and jan are twins
they're not twins they're very they look
they looked and I think they were twins
ok i know for and they're just I don't
know Jan maybe others and that's the
part that freaks me out like in fact cuz
I've known Fran for 10 years easy and
then I find out he has a twin that looks
exactly like him that freaks me out now
you're making me now you're make god
these I've known them I haven't seen
either one of them for a million years
but now I'm bummed out if they're not
twins okay but I was maybe I thought
brother August other sister huh brothers
Jana duder yeah okay two to two dudes
okay um hmm
if you had twins would you give them
rhyming name names like that I don't
know I haven't thought about it I go I
don't know yeah I don't know what rhymes
with Frank stank I don't think that's a
good name skank skank is a girl Frank ok
sorry skank but you were born second we
really like Frank although if we were to
write a zombie movie perhaps the zombie
family that lives next door they're twin
kids could be stankin skank yeah
fraternal once the boy wants a girl oh I
thought you were gonna say like Frank is
Frank is the actual human twin and skank
is so you can have a zombie twin and
they're both boys yeah oh oh yeah you
could have a zombie twin sure maybe
stank should be the zombie twins first
baby is born alive and the second baby
is born undead oh I know look we're
making up did you think there was gonna
be this phrase that a little easier a
little bit a little nicer hey is there a
non creepy zombie baby way to describe
it ok I feel like I nailed it in fact
your reaction is what i was looking for
then well done sir yeah better now
spinka de zombie baby that's one of the
tracks on my CD oh really now it's not
not Christmas card my sure yeah I'm on
my shameless plug tour yeah well people
should it's called rusty cow and how did
you come up that's the Alzheimer no see
that's my impression of Alzheimer's host
um-hmm rusty cow um so do you have any
the alzheimers show that's what you
should do else heimer al simer so it's
not you don't hear the Z too much in
there yeah that's my that's my but
that's my name yeah yeah yeah then I
also it's like a late night it's like a
forgetful yeah it's like Al Franken and
I'm the one who's not in on the joke
yeah yeah very popular because I'm
always forgetting things I can't
remember things and it's the same type
of joke over and over but I'm not in on
it right and who's your sidekick um
zombie baby
I feel like it's so easy to make TV show
I don't know why people are laboring
over it is on adult swim right now I
don't watch some of the stuff on his own
adult swim I don't feel like I smoke
enough pot to watch the fun adults you
almost have to i downloaded the adult
swim app and i watched something that i
could not make head or tail it was like
how first of all Bravo because it was so
competitive aren't surreal but second of
all like it doesn't it's not just one
person who writes it and draws it and
animates it and then puts the soundtrack
and the music and the credits on you
have to tell someone else what you're
trying to do yeah yeah and then get them
on the same page to make that states
it's yeah dolt swim is good but else the
Alzheimer else I'm Alzheimer shells I
mercyme leo miss with his sidekick
zombie baby I feel like holy [ __ ] man
who do we call dude somebody we got it
we know tons of people who work at adult
swim I do we we must I don't think I
doesn't Prabhu sane have a show on adult
swim does he I think so he's a San
Francisco guy right yeah uh I think so I
think I know him from there I know he's
a guy who dresses up when he does a show
um Oh Brian yeah i haven't seen brian
for a while he's also a gamer yeah big
gamers man i try asked him about his
part he does a podcast where they play
Dungeons and Dragons oh really on the
podcast oh wow you know jack occasion
must be all over that I don't know I
don't know what she's doing yeah well
I've dungeons and dragons are like
that's kind of like them isn't that like
the sergeant pepper's of nerd games what
is sergeant pepper's the sergeant
pepper's of music would you all music
but you know when you think rock and
roll you know you think the kind of like
the the back in the day the album the
classic album is sergeant pepper's I'm
kind of feel like oh I thought I can
work dress up dress up albums that could
be it that could be the cosplay of yeah
yeah that all right okay sergeant
pepper's is the cosplay of music records
records albums yeah okay now
that's what I meant to say we've got so
many ideas we've got the cosplay of
comedy in a DVD sure that we're gonna
make we've got the two grey haired guys
with Scottish hats to or we're going to
be doing which are coming to Brighton
yeah that's we're gonna kick off the
tour mm-hmm we start with we get the
kinks out on the road yeah yeah bring it
to the big to the big city yeah yeah and
then what else do what else other we got
a big following in Leeds yeah tell how
they have to stop there for my sounds
you just making I've been to Brighton
I've been to Leeds okay good for you
yeah I've been to Worthing top that I
can't I've been to London that's it
that's it that's it we're gonna go to
some other places when I'm in London
this time to do my show at the soho
theatre all right the end of June are
you doing this or theatre yes sir Oh
awesome I never done that before have
you done it no dodo I'm excited about it
I've only been to Costa Rica one time
hmm didn't want to move there no no I
found it to be a little bit do you speak
Spanish you'd have to speak Spanish no
they're very they're very a lot of
expats for there so people and we're one
of the few countries who don't encourage
learning other languages know where one
of the countries who feels like we why
learn another language we have being the
greatest [ __ ] language in the world
so you can really you can find a lot of
people English is no problem and a lot
of places actually accept american
currency yes I did find that to be true
yeah yeah and but when you use Puerto
Rico Rican why am I in Puerto Rico all
of a sudden when you use Costa Rican
currency it's like I remember I had a
bar I stayed at a hotel that had a bar
that's like you just pay at the end of
the week and I'm like okay that's cool
so you don't have to really exchange
money and i got my tab and it was like
450,000 whatever I first are you yeah
and which turned out to be like 85 bucks
I was worried in those situations that
they're at because you're drinking right
yeah you're letting them keep track of
how much you drink and your kind of
trusting them and i spent over a period
of days hmm i'd be a little nervous that
they were gonna tag on something well
not or not because I'm I'm xenophobic
but I feel like any American Bar if you
were you got into a situation like the
bar
corner where you just pay him every
Monday oh yeah forget about it yeah it's
gonna show up in a nicer car every every
month yeah courtesy of you just says
thanks Jake and on the license plate
yeah you know you're in trouble when
they named one of the urinals after you
hahaha bar this is a good time man but I
have to go pick up my son I get it I
apologize no I was gonna suggest that
maybe the weed weed really we feel like
so grateful like so grateful like I feel
grateful that you've come over to be on
the podcast Marie oh I'm happy to be
here man and I'm very excited to listen
to your CD I hope people who are
listening to us will go and download it
nah or you can if you go to marry
valeriano com I will happily sign it for
you fork over for one of these babies uh
on my websites 12 bucks twelve bucks
that is cheap it is cheap man I know
does she go to starbucks it's like 16
bucks and then then and you get this
plastic thing inside of this cardboard
thing with another thing in there that I
haven't even seen no wait till you open
it it's like a party and then they come
to your show and you sign them yeah
right yeah happy to do it okay thank you
Thank You Jake let's high five oh okay
this is fun awesome
well there you have it ladies and
gentlemen it was nice of you to stop by
that's a metaphor course I stopped by
you more than you stopped by me because
you're doing whatever you do and i just
showed up right in your ears you you
made that happen of course with your
behaviors on the internets Jake this
podcast is always free though so you
don't have to feel bad about yourself
for downloading a thing and then
listening to it wherever I hope maybe
you're naked i don't care if it's comfy
if its cold if you're if you're naked
and cold what my god you need to put
some clothes on put pause this thing can
get your pants on thank you for
listening don't give up there'll be
plenty of time to give up later I always
say if someone was kind enough kind of
write these names down someone sent me
sweet email but how they were running a
some kind of distance running was it a
marathon oh my god I'm butchering this
but shout out shout out to you people
who don't give up and for those of you
who have given up it's not hopefully
it's not too late to give it another try
and this next time don't give up they'll
be plenty of time to give up later hang
in there yeah enjoy enjoy yourself
brawling this together these are these
are the motivation are the things that I
say at the end of the show when I'm
delirious and delighted to be done with
the my responsibilities for the show for
a week and then it starts over I wake up
tomorrow and I do it all again believe
it or not there this takes some planning
and preparation it's not that doesn't
just happen however long it takes you to
listen to it takes me way longer than
that to make it happen because of
because of because of planning or maybe
it's because of poor planning maybe if I
was a better planner it wouldn't take me
as long to do all this but believe me I
get enough of that crap from my wife I
don't need to be telling myself that
here in the podcast luckily there's no
way she's made she's never made it this
far into an episode so I know she didn't
hear that I love you bye bye